the ukrainians are running out of
ammunition
the ammunition that they used to call
them 155 millimeter weapons and uh the
running out of those that ammunition and
we're low on it
but that reality won't stop the US from
sending more to Ukraine the country
reportedly fires the same amount of 155
millimeter artillery rounds in five days
as we're able to produce in a month
but this Administration they don't care
and if you had any doubts about who's
actually running America's war effort in
Ukraine listen to what John Kirby said
to our own Shannon bream defense
industry obviously wants to make sure
that if they're going to increase
production that you know that that
production rate is going to stay
elevated for a period of time that's
sort of the central thesis here of the
of the discussions that we're having
with them is to get them to increase
production and let them know that you
know we're serious about doing that for
for some period of time here
joining me now is Ohio Senator JD Vance
senator now we all get mocked for
warning against the military-industrial
complex you know I always go back to
well Dwight D Eisenhower little you know
knew a little bit about it and here John
Kirby all but admits it
yeah that's exactly right Laura it's
pretty scary stuff when he's basically
saying that the profit motives of the
defense contractors are motivating our
posture in the Ukraine what's so
unbelievable about this Laura is that
those of us who have been warning about
this have been saying for a year and a
half that our posture in Ukraine would
deplete our ammunition deplete our
missiles deplete the systems that we
need to God forbid fight the next War to
send to the Taiwanese so that they can
focus on the real threat in this world
which is the Chinese what you're seeing
now as the President of the United
States saying that the American people
were running out of bullets we're not
making enough ammunition to arm our own
troops or to arm our allies for a war of
the future and yet these same people
will continue to say that we can send
more more to Ukraine we need to stop
supporting the Ukrainian war effort at
the very least until we have enough
bullets for our own troops now Senator
my reaction to something that former
president Trump said yesterday
I know zielinski very well I felt he was
very honorable because when they asked
him about the perfect phone call that I
made he said it was indeed that's not
going to be enough for Putin to stop
bombing no no no I'm not saying that I
had a good relationship very good with
both of them I would tell Putin if you
don't make a deal we're going to give
them a lot we're going to give more than
they ever got if we have to
Senator
um you know somebody I know what he
meant to say there but
some some people were worried some
populist conservatives were worried
because it seemed like that was Lindsey
Graham speaking toward the end about
giving them more and more weapons but
what's your reaction
yeah here's how I take it Laura first of
all president Trump has been the lone
voice in the wilderness crying we've got
to stop the killing we've got to stop
this war it's not in our interest it's
not in anybody else's interest for this
to continue that the way that I took him
Laura is is making a very obvious and
simple point which is that the Americans
we have leverage here we have leverage
over the Russians they don't want to
continue the war we have leverage over
the ukrainians they can't continue the
war unless we continue to support them
and I think president Trump is saying
look we need to use that leverage we're
the world superpower we can stop the
fighting if we want to this idea that
this is ultimately Russia and Ukraine's
decision it's ridiculous America has
been an important party from day one
from before this war even started let's
use our leverage and bring this thing to
a close that's what the president's
saying and I agree with it
um but Senator McConnell and Joe Biden
are on the same page on this as is
Lindsey Graham who's obviously very
close to president Trump and again it's
not personal toward anyone but they have
a very clear POV here very quickly is
the Senate ever going to relent on this
non-stop weapons to Ukraine
not yet Laura to be honest with you not
yet there are about 10 of us who are
pushing back against this we need 51 to
really stop it that's why the best
chance to bring this war to a close is
is to get a better president in 2024.
looking forward to it Senator thank you
for joining us at 7 pm Eastern hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else